[Musique]
le pays noir au nord de la france de
vastes étendues plates seuls s'ils
dressent les terry les chevalets et
l'alignement des corps labeur principal
n'est pas sur terre mais dessous dans la
mine ici vivent ce que l'on nomme
affectueusement les gueules noires
les travailleurs du charbon chaque matin
depuis plus d'un siècle des cages des
emmène de la surface vers le fond dans
les galeries d'extraction
[Musique]
vers 1900 les mineurs du nord et du
pas-de-calais travail est dix heures par
jour
samedi concours la lutte pour leur
dignité sociale pour leur sécurité dans
le travail a été longue
ceux qui ont été mineurs de fond avant
la dernière guerre s'en souviennent
ainsi l'un des leurs pierre des halles
devenu depuis journalistes au moins
j'étais aubry peur c'était un match
épouvantable mais c'est terrible ces
hommes-là été condamné à mort aucun de
mes camarades est encore en vie il en
aura 40 ans en 45 ans mort de troy
silicose c'était obligatoire
dans des compagnies l'enfant désormais
c'est être sur des enfants qu'en
faisaient descendre à 13 ans d'un match
épouvantable dans des galeries très
basses où il est c'est à l'occasion des
lambeaux de peau sur les boîtes cassé
à 13 ans il était calibos jusque 18 ans
et un mineur à 18 ans seulement et
minéraux retour du régiment ça veut dire
qu'à un mineur ont formé en sept ou huit
années c'est un métier difficile avant
avant la nationalisation des
charbonnages les mines étaient
exploitées par des compagnies privées
les mineurs également en 1906 la
compagnie de courrières employait
environ 7000 personnes dont 5700 au fond
le travailleurs étaient payés à la tâche
aux roms métiers pénibles dangereux pour
des salaires trop bas
il fallait bien que les actionnaires
aient leur profit le charbon c'était
alors l'énergie l'or noir des années
1900 2500 tonnes extraites en 1905
le mineur n'était alors qu'une machine à
produire
je crois qu'une anecdote qui vous
montrons comment pourrait peut-être en
quelles conditions nous exploitaient si
on peut encore le mot un jour je me
trouvais dans la changer et puis un
éboulement ce produit là où je
travaillais j'ai dû fuir fuir vers le
remblai pour me protéger
et puis mes outils ont été ensevelis
bien sûr les api retrouve réduit les
payer
après le travail l'existence précaire
dans les corons éclairé aucun qu au fond
le mineur emportait un maigre
casse-croûte le bric est rentré chez lui
il trouvait là légumes cher et la viande
rares
nous étions des sommes nombreux dans ces
cours ont servi en les compagnies destin
était presque presque tracé dès la
naissance
fils de mineur devions mineurs
son honneur c'est le courage et
l'honnêteté
ce sont des gens extraordinaires
voici la concession de courrières en
[Musique]
samedi 10 mars au petit matin
depuis deux jours un incendie s'est
déclaré dans une veine il a été réduit
interdite par des levées de terre mais
le danger demeure ciment sur nos méric
délégués du personnel s'adresse à cet
amas
comment si le feu de local ruling devait
se propager
ce serait la catastrophe en ma qualité
de délégué mineur la sécurité je vous
invite à ne pas d'essence ça paie pour
les dégâts
il y mène fatalement
la direction considère qu'il n'y a plus
aucun danger en descente et l'ozone de
descendre immédiatement comme un gamin
de 10 ans 10 ans
[Musique]
l'habitude d'obéir est plus forte que
l'instinct de conservation
les mineurs vont descendre malgré le
danger
[Musique]
les gens
[Applaudissements]
la maison le bruit avait déjà couru il
est arrivé que des cendres les enfants
les habillant des tests et ils ont mis
ma carrière aller à l'école aléas les
côtes dans les rues tout ça les femmes
courent et part à droite à gauche il
catastrophe une catastrophe sans pleurer
nous demander les jeunes qu'est ce que
c'est une catastrophe
envoyez tous les femmes courir sur une
passerelle était qui relié le public
nous sommes donc partis de cette
passerelle
nous n'avons pas été à l'école et alors
c'est pas trés septembre aux minables
abordable les aiguilles les pleurs là et
bien si on commençait déjà à augmenter
et quelques personnes qu'ils étaient à
l'accrochage son bord il va plus à se
trouver et qui expliqué qu'ils ne
regrettent rien le tout nous l'afrique
si sallaumines méricourt billy-montigny
le bassin de courrières s'étend sur
plusieurs kilomètres
un réseau de galeries relie les puits de
mine et les puits d'aération
ce décloisonnement serait salutaire en
cas d'inondation mais aujourd'hui ils
intensifiera la catastrophe
il étendra sur 100 kilomètres de voies
souterraines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le puits 3 est obstruée impossible d'y
descendre certains parviennent à
remonter par les échelles du puits
d'aération
[Musique]
seul le puits numéro deux est utilisable
par les premiers sauveteurs dont briques
personne ne connaît encore l'ampleur du
désastre une explosion géante a ravagé
le fond les gaz de l' incendie mal
éteint ont déclenché un énorme coup de
poussière
ceux qui ne sont pas morts sous le choc
seront presque tous asphyxié sur place
mon père était parti travailler et on se
demandait quoi j'ai un autre qui est
venu vous savez et puis qu'il ya dix ans
maman tous et prépare de l'augusta il va
revenir répit consorts il va revenir et
il n'est jamais revenu l'eau est resté
sur le feu toute la journée quoi et
alors après on a su mon mental et route
de reconnaître le corps de papa il
n'était pas abîmée pas pas du tout on
l'a ramené le dimanche et dans son
cercueil
mais les cercueils étaient ouverts alors
digipryn j'ai pris une chaise ça je ne
sais pas plus lâches est mieux acceptée
j'ai monté sur la chaîne et j'embrasse
hainaut perdra le cercueil ils n'étaient
pas défigurer juste une petite croûte
sur le nez on l'avait retrouvé asphyxié
au fond de la mine le savez vous contera
bois il était contraint drôle comme ça
pendant cette terrible journée
l'angoissent s'installe à courrières
inlassablement parler puis deux et
quatre les sauveteurs essayent de
descendre ce qui remonte
car tous ne remonteront pas rapporte
avec eux des corps disloqué
[Musique]
simon riquet les autres multiplient la
descente en vain la plupart du temps
les pompiers de paris arrive en renfort
avec un matériel ultramoderne les
allemands viennent à leur rescousse à
leur tour malgré le différend qui oppose
la france et l'allemagne
à propos du maroc
[Musique]
sur les lieux mêmes de la catastrophe
l'harmonie des mineurs d'ostricourt
jaune devant une chapelle ardente
[Musique]
au silo de méricourt sont enterrés dans
une fosse commune
tous les corps non identifiés la france
l'europe entière a une pensée pour
courrières le jour des obsèques mercredi
13 mars 1906 les trains ont amené une
foule immense
il neige toutes les cloches de village
seul ministre député évêques suivent le
cortège message secours aux familles
arrivent de partout
le député lamendin prononce un discours
violent
ils réclament la recherche des
responsabilités ils parlent de faute et
de crimes interdisant qu'on
l'applaudisse sur les temps l'ingénieur
en chef veut parler à son tour on lui
crie silence ta place n'est pas ici
[Musique]
on
des familles entières sont anéantis
[Musique]
je l'appelais deux frères m'ont ampleur
paramore il reste 6 et d'office lycée
joseph des plantes et ils sont
versatiles arthur et tout ceci dit après
ce stage était mon cousin
car établi qu il est nu ça va pisser
[Musique]
afin rappaport est alors deux les maris
de ses deux soeurs et alors ça faisait
quatre débats dans la famille vous voyez
ça pour la grand mère le court ça lui a
fait j'ai toujours vu ma mère en noir de
cheminots ne plus jamais remise de clerc
savez elle est restée dans sa maison
elle payer le loyer c'était deux ans lui
retenait de francs par mois
enfin il ne nous a pas rassurés
elle a travaillé elle fait beaucoup de
lessive et puis des travaux comme ça
fait dur pour maman en satin confondues
[Musique]
j'ai eu à livrer de caisse d'epargne
j'avais tellement beaucoup dessus que
quand on s'est mariés jeu gta costumes à
mon mari avec la fois par jour vasseur
en mls
et elle ne s'est pas beaucoup avec le
chagrin l'indignation
cinq jours après la catastrophe neuf
mille mineurs sont en grève le 20 mars
il 150000 paris inquiète envoie sur
place deux escadrons et en haillons la
grève est venu de la base spontanée
instinctive devant les puits des piquets
arrêtent ceux qui viennent aux nouvelles
on ne descend plus camarades un dévale
points aujourd'hui
il est indéniable que le malheur de
courrières à souder le monde ouvrier
dans la solidarité
il se trouve que cette catastrophe se
produit
début 1900 si c'est à dire à une date
qui coïncide avec des dates très
importante dans l'histoire du mouvement
ouvrier en france il faut en effet se
souvenir que si la fondation du parti
radical de 1901 la fondation de la et
sefyu qui unifie les multiples
mouvements socialistes et de 1905 et que
cette en 1904 que les socialistes dès
lors conscients de leur très grande
force décident eux-mêmes pour mieux
jouer leur propre jeu de ne plus
soutenir les gouvernements bourgeois du
centre gauche en france en place depuis
c'est une époque la belle époque
indienne où la classe ouvrière prague
puissamment est pleinement conscience de
ses propres possibilités et c'est à ce
moment là que la catastrophe de
courrières vient à point rappeler aux
partis ouvriers et à la cgt qui a
elle-même vient de naître que outre un
combat de salaire outre un combat de la
dignité
il y as pour les ouvriers le combat de
la sécurité à mener et c'est pourquoi la
date de courrières se trouve être
extrêmement important la grève se durcit
le nouveau ministre de l'intérieur c'est
georges clemenceau il dit à talence un
mot d'ordre cours parmi les mineurs qui
ont cessé le travail
vite et 8,8 heures de travail par jour 8
francs de salaire les revendications des
bouches
çà et là sur la violence
[Musique]
basly député maire de lens socialistes
dirigent les modérés du vieux syndicats
[Musique]
broutchoux pour sa part est à la tête du
parti
dur ils se réclament de la marche au
syndicalisme très populaire via le sens
des formules de choc après une émeute il
sera arrêté du condamné à deux mois de
prison
quatorze blessés un officier tué à lens
clemenceau bien à son front mais les
drapeaux rouges et noirs se montre
partout
[Musique]
le 30 mars coup de théâtre d'un jour
après la catastrophe
13 survivants sorte de la fosse 2 à
billy montigny
ils ont cheminé pendant tout ce temps
d'un puits bloqué à un éboulis écrasé de
fatigue mourant de faim et de soif et
les voici
c'est incroyable
sous terre le galibot ans elle nous
prouve aux 16 ans a rencontré son père
charles par un extraordinaire hasard le
fils d'anselme se souvient c'était la
ruée vers les grilles parce que chacun
espérait que ce soit le sien son fils ou
son père alors ma grand mère est arrivée
elle a même dit je me souviens d'une
anecdote à lundi on aurait dit que on
aurait dit que les gens savaient que
c'était mon mari mon garçon pascal passé
comme ça puis elle se fraye h mais s'en
sort en résistance soria c'est elle qui
dit ça à brive ou alors bon bah elle
était arrivée à la goutte de lait et
puis ils n'ont pas pu le voir tout de
suite parce qu'ils y étaient faibles
sortant d un moment puis après elle a
dit même à ma part à tout petit coin
mais je veux le voir alors on lui a
permis d'y aller mais docteur lantieri
il faudra être très sage ni madame alors
elle était le voir et puis en arrivant
est d'abord tombé dans les pommes et
puis elle n'arrêtait pas de tomber
docteur il a même fait une réflexion il
a dit lui est sauvé mais si ça continue
c'est elle qui va rester dedans alors
elle s'est approchée de mon grand père
mon grand père lui a pris la main il a
embrassé puis 10 à dire pas toi j'ai
bien brees pour team
alors prêts à hadar tomber dans les
pommes naturellement si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi
et les voir brad est parti voir mon père
oui mon père y avait il reconnu tout de
suite sa mère puis a dit aman maintenant
on pourrais m'acheter à vélo c'était des
rescapés comme l'on disait en patois du
nord
un mot que pour hier fait entrer dans la
langue française
l'histoire de ces hommes perdus est
terrible il marchait aveuglément dans
l'obscurité complète suivant les tuyaux
pour s'orienter à peu près deux petits
groupes celui du père pruvost et celui
du fils firent jonction parmi rave et
dit je te jure prévost j'ai vu ton fils
alors il dit lequel j'en ai deux a dit
je ne sais pas lequel mais j'ai vu ton
fils alors là mon grand père n'étant que
j'aurai des gens je n'arrêterai pas pour
le retrouver et à beaux jours se sont
retrouvés ils ont crié lors ce moment là
le vieux rivaux il ya un cahier mon
garçon on s'aime
alors évidemment ne se voyait pas mais
conclut le père et le fils se sont
rencontrés il se sent un de ces rescapés
honoré couplet avait évoqué pour la
radio c'est vraiment dramatique
quelques temps avant sa mort l'année
dernière il avait rongé les corps se
déboîte soutènement il avait bu leur
urine
mais la chance leur vin quand ils
trouvèrent un cheval vivant qui allait
devenir nourriture nous avons couché une
berline vide en avant du fal et une
derrière
de ce fait le cheval ne pouvait pas
avancer ni reculer et c'est comme ça
qu'une camarade d'englos il a frappé à
tour de bras dans la tête du cheval mais
plus beau repas qu'ils ont fait c'est
quand ils ont ils ont trouvé à son
d'avoine allez en manger d'avoine c'est
pour ça qu'il avait plus de gens qui
n'avaient plus rien à manger dubois de
laval
mais c'était son plus beau repas qui
modifient
le ministre louis barthou remettent à
deux survivants n'est ni et charles
prevost la croix de la légion d'honneur
[Musique]
le 4 avril 24 jours après le désastre
un dernier survivant sort des pluies
auguste berton il n'y en aura pas
d'autre 11 cents mineurs ont péri à
courrières
[Musique]
la grève cependant n'aboutit pas elle
s'éternise malgré les secours
la misère s'installe en pays noir il
fait froid il faut récupérer des débris
de charbon dans le fouillis des terrines
[Musique]
4 mai la grève est finie le travail
reprend partout la catastrophe pourtant
ne sera jamais oublié ni ses leçons de
vigilance les compagnies privées ont
disparu la sécurité dans la mine a été
renforcée les morts de courrières ont
servi à cela aujourd'hui à méricourt les
mineurs de la fosse 3 continue
d'extraire le chat
[Musique]